Billy Bush speaks out days after Matt
Lauer is fired from the Today Show over
allegations of sexual misconduct and
slams president
Donald Trump
[Music]
the 46 year old penned an op-ed for the
New York Times on Sunday and opened up
about the 2016 release of that infamous
tape from 2005 in which Bush is heard
laughing and joking as Trump makes lewd
comments about women the scandal
ultimately cost Bush his job on The
Today Show quote there were seven other
guys present on the bus at the time and
every single one of us assumed we were
listening to a crass stand-up act
we now know better Bush who was working
for Access Hollywood at the time
explained his reaction to Trump's
inappropriate remarks the key to
succeeding in my line of work was
establishing a strong rapport with
celebrities I did that and was rewarded
for it the TV personality also weighed
in on reports that Trump is allegedly
claiming it's not him on the tape quote
this has hit a raw nerve in me I can
only imagine how it has reopened the
wounds of the women who came forward
with their stories about him and did not
receive enough attention
[Music]